hey it's Justine and today we are
checking out the brand new refresh model
3 I am so excited about this I have been
driving it for about a week I did a road
trip all the way up to San Diego and
back and I've been daily driving it
pretty much every single day it makes me
upset though because as a Model S plaid
owner I could have had almost three of
these for the price that I paid for my
plaid and I might almost enjoy driving
this more
[Music]
the first thing that you're going to
notice with this new model 3 is how
Sleek the design looks it is much more
aerodynamic and you can actually tell
just by looking at it it's more angular
and it just looks so sharp and crisp and
premium you can also tell a new refresh
here to the headlights and this also has
the new hardware for cameras which we'll
talk more about later but all in all
this thing looks beautiful and I'm
obsessed with this color I'm actually
not a huge fan of the the color red but
when I first saw this red that they came
out with on the model S and the X I was
like okay that looks so much better and
now they have brought it here to the
model 3 and you can tell it looks
awesome now not only do they have the
new Ultra red but they also have this
version available in the stealth gray
which is really really pretty as well so
the model three that I'm testing out is
the long range now this comes with the
standard 18in Photon Wheels you can
upgrade if you want to the 19in Nova
Wheels but that will give you a decrease
in range so for example if I have the
18inch I'll get about 341 miles whereas
the 19 is going to drop you down to 304
is estimated and for me it's all about
range so that's a
noo now as we make our way towards the
back you'll notice a side profile looks
pretty similar but one of my favorite
parts that they have here is the new
Tesla badging you no longer have the
logo you don't have to get an
aftermarket one which I know armondo's
excited about now these tail lights the
previous model had split tails light
design so this one is a nice unibody so
the tail lights take themselves up with
the trunk now while the trunk is up
you'll notice these reflector lights
also turn on and this diffuser kind of
just really makes it have a more
performance
feel now obviously all of these design
changes make this new model 3 look
really freaking cool but it's not just
for looks it's actually to help enhance
the performance the efficiency and the
long range performance and this is done
by reducing the drag coefficiency and
you can really tell they made this so
much more aerodynamic just by looking at
the hood it's lower it's sharper and
because of this angle that's what is
really giving us that better performance
another update is the rear windows
actually have dual pane glass now now in
the previous model 3 they were only in
the front so now you have all four
Windows dual pane which really helps
with the sound inside of the cabin and
you can really notice it when you're
driving this also has this nice new
alcatara fabric here on the doors and
it's so soft like I could just lay my
head on it and take a little nap and
above it you will see this little LED
light you can't actually see it now
because it's super bright out but this
led runs all throughout the cabin it's
very similar to what the Cyber truck has
you can even customize the color and of
course I made mine pink now hopping in
the back seat this already has such a
more premium feel this has new vegan
leather seats they're also perforated
and even this back here used to be like
a plasticky and this also has the vegan
leather that kind of covers the entire
thing so already it just feels like a
much comfier Cozier ride but the St of
the show is this new 8in display so this
is awesome because if you do have
passengers they're able to watch Netflix
control their temperature and you can
even control the passenger seat you
can't control the driver's seat because
obviously that wouldn't be safe for your
driver but here we go look going
up going back we do also have heated
seats back here and the other cool thing
about this display is you can connect it
to Bluetooth so if you have some little
passengers back here you don't want to
listen to Children's content uh while
you're driving you can give them some
Bluetooth headphones and you're good to
go now inside in the front seats which
are extremely comfortable and they do
feel so much like my S like everything
about this just feels like such a huge
upgrade the other thing that I like
about these seats is they have cooling
the other thing that is a huge
difference is this now no longer has
stocks took me about a year to get used
to these turn signals you basically have
to press the buttons and that's how you
have your turn signal which now I can't
live without but it definitely takes a
while to get used to I do like that they
actually made this a real horn because
on the first version of The Plaid it
drove me insane like I'd be driving and
I would have to hit the horn couldn't
even find it because it's a tiny little
button worst design ever moving on to
things that I do like the updated screen
it has less bezels this also has a nice
cloth right here on the interior which
that used to be wood which I wasn't a
huge fan of and again you can see the
LED just going throughout the front here
which looks so cool at night the other
thing that that you have to know is if
you do want to put this into drive or
reverse you will have to use the screen
or they have now placed it up here on
the top kind of like in the Cyber Tru so
you can see I can press Park reverse
neutral or drive but all of that can
also be done right here on the display
now i' mentioned Hardware 4 and with
these upgraded cameras it has made such
a huge difference and this will also
help if you do have full self-driving
using Tesla Vision you'll be able to get
much more PR ice driving and as you can
see with the cameras when I pull them up
everything just looks so clear and crisp
with this update and the new cameras I
love how it gives you kind of this 3D
representation of the world around you
it's also got these little heat map
sensors so you can tell if you're close
to something so it's been very helpful
when I've been parking well I think now
it's time to take it for a drive uh
let's go oh Drive is over
[Music]
there
so we're now in the car and I've been
driving this for about a week I did like
I mentioned a road trip up to San Diego
and back and during that time it was the
worst rainfall that I have ever
encountered in Los Angeles San Diego was
flooding thankfully I got out the thing
that I noticed so much is how incredible
this was handling in torrential
downpours what was actually really great
is because the cameras are now a much
higher quality it really was kind of
giving me that confidence to just know
that I was following the car in front of
me because I really could not even see
the lines on the road because the
weather was so bad so that being my
first introduction to this vehicle I was
so impressed with it so I've had the
Tesla Model S plaid for the past gosh
almost like 2 and a half years now and
it has been such an incredible car and I
just really thought that like nothing
could ever be better nothing could even
come close and then I got behind the
wheel of this and it really did have
that same kind of Premium feeling that I
was used to in the Plaid s I also love
that I kind of am sitting up a little
bit higher whereas the S is a little bit
lower and I do feel like it hugs the
road a lot more this I can cruise over
bumps the suspension feels nice and soft
and I'm just I don't have a care in the
world it seems like and the other thing
is the price difference between these
vehicles this being the entry model
Tesla this does not feel entry model to
me everything that they have done as far
as the upgrades with the interior even
just the steering wheel like this feels
like something that you would be paying
a much higher price tag for which is
kind of
[Music]
surprising let's punch it
ready okay now it doesn't have the
extreme pickup that the Plaid does but
I'm going to tell you that you're not
going to be disappointed because it
definitely will get the job done if you
need to fire off that line when you're
at a red light it's going to do it are
you are you okay over there yeah yeah
yeah I know it's pretty good this feels
like the long range with the upgraded
performance boost that you had to pay
before which is now you get it standard
I mentioned that this does have now
double pan glass in the front and the
rear this feels super quiet there's also
something that I noticed it has like
this little hook that kind of latches in
when you close the door I initially
thought that was just something to help
me kick the door open a little bit
easier but it actually kind of latches
the door in place and gives you a much
tighter seal it's pretty quiet All
Things Considered and if you've never
been in an electric vehicle before and
just like punched it the fact that
there's just no sound and you just start
speeding off into the distance is just
so impressive it is a feeling unlike any
other so this model does not have full
self-driving this does have kind of like
the lane assist and I used it almost all
the way to San Diego and really for me
when I'm driving that's honestly all I
need this has some upgraded side impact
protection so Teslas are definitely
known as really safe Vehicles so now
with these upgraded features it makes
this model 3 even safer than the
previous this has an upgraded telematics
control unit so this will help with your
connectivity and your Wi-Fi it even has
a dual mic for taking conference calls
which I take a ton of in my car this
will definitely improve your audio I
don't actually know how it sounds on the
other end but I've had no complaints so
far which is pretty awesome and with the
all-wheel drive trim you're going to get
17 speakers and two subwoofers which
definitely will enhance your musical
experience if you will the other thing
that surprised me with Teslas is before
I was a Tesla owner they didn't look
like they would have a lot of storage
and I was pleasantly surprised how much
storage space it actually has these
seats will pop down so you're able to
put tons of suitcases tons of luggage
and of course there is some under trunk
storage and you've got the frunk you can
put so much in this thing that it's
pretty incredible so in the past week
I've had so much fun with this car and
it's been kind of cool because a lot of
people have stopped me and have wanted
to look inside and take a peek because
this car has been out I think in China
and in the UK right now and it's just
coming to the US so seeing this thing
kind kind of driving around like it does
look a little bit different even valet
was like I've never seen one of these
before what are these cool lights so
it's been so fun getting to talk to
people about the car and my experience I
also shot a review about two and a half
years ago on my plaid that I never
posted so if you guys want to see that
let me know if you want to see a
six-month impression versus 2 and 1/2
years we can see how my opinions have
changed over the past 2 years I also
just recently got an r1t which I'm super
stoked about just got it wrapped have a
few little accessories that I'm putting
on so so be sure to like comment and
subscribe for more videos about electric
vehicles Tech and honestly who knows
what happens on my channel it's a
surprise we'll see you guys in the next
one bye